hi if you're familiar with adrenaline
rush then you will be familiar with
flight-or-fight response so which tells
us in a confused situation whether to
fight back or run away but I'm not going
to talk about flight and fight response
rather I would talk about how
epinephrine regulates one aspect of this
flight and flight response and under
stress condition how epinephrine
regulates glucose sentences and glucose
is important because glucose is the raw
source of fuel for the body under stress
condition definitely let's say a scary
dog is barking at you are trying to bite
you so your immediate response would be
running away from that dog in order to
run away your muscles of the neck need
to contract and expand enough very fast
rate in other words it needs a lot of
energy ATP but what does that ATP come
from definitely muscle cells need a lot
of glucose fuel to make ATP now in the
muscle cell
where does glucose come from in a muscle
cell which is kind of a resolver of
reserve glucose in format of glycogen
need to be broken down immediately to
glucose and that glucose could be in
turn used as a fuel to permit and make
ATP and thereby contracting muscle very
fast and running away so let's just see
how the adrenaline rush works so
epinephrine by not to the beta
adrenergic receptor on the muscle cells
and allowing g-protein cascade to occur
the G alpha subunit of this G protein
replaces its GDP with gtp and gets
activated it in turns activate adenylate
cyclase which formed ATP to cyclic A&P a
cyclic EMP activates protein kinase a or
PKA and releases its catalytic subunit
from the regulatory subunits the
catalytic subunits are important the
catalytic subunit of PKA phosphorylates
phosphorylase kinase and converts it
into an active form of phosphorus
now first of all I understand it is very
important because it controls several
important rate-limiting enzyme in the
glycogenolysis pathway where glycogen is
broken down to glucose so let us see
what phosphorylase kinase control
phosphorylase kinase convert
phosphorylase to an active format now
once
phosphor is is activated it can start
the process of glycogenolysis where
glycogen would be broken down to produce
glucose so we saw that how epinephrine
can in turn work by a g-protein
signaling cascade lead to protein kinase
a activation and thereby activation of
phosphorus which is a key enzyme in
glycogen eliza's pathway and thereby a
fast glucose burning mechanism could
occur in the muscles and that gives us
the energy to run away from that scary
talk so if you like my video give it a
big thumbs up don't forget to Like share
and subscribe thank you